in this video we're going to be going
through a pre-calculus midterm exam
review and we're going to be going
through 60 Questions together so I have
videos on all these different topics so
if you struggle with any of these
particular topics you can search those
on my Mario's math tutoring YouTube
channel to get more uh help and
assistance with those but let's dive in
there should be a good sampling of the
types of problems you're likely to see
on your exam so this first example here
it says AV valuate F ofx = to x^2 - 2x
now evaluate just means find the value
and this is basically testing us on the
function notation remember whatever's in
parentheses that's like our input or our
x value so whatever here is in
parentheses that's going to go in for X
on the right side of the equation no
matter how many X's there are you're
going to want to replace it with this
input or this -4 so let's go ahead and
do that so that comes out to -4 2ar - 2
* -4 now whenever I do the substitution
I always like to put it in parenthesis
to treat it like a group that's
important so then you're going to
evaluate using the order of operations
uh parentheses exponents multiplication
division addition subtraction the
pemos -42 we know is 16 -2 * -4 is POS 8
so this just comes out to 24 so the x
value is-4 the Y value or the output
would be 24 let's go to number two now
this one's a little bit more challenging
because see how we have this quantity X
Plus H inside the parenthesis we're
going to have to substitute that in
place of the X on the right so when we
do this it's going to look something
like this x + h^ 2 - 2 * that quantity x
+ H now you don't want to make this
mistake some students what they'll do is
they'll just Square the X and square the
H but when you have a binomial squared
you want to think of this as x + H *
another X+ H and then what you can do is
you can foil this out uh so x * X gives
us X2 X * H gives us xh H * X gives us
another xh and H * H gives us h^ 2ar
here I'm going to take this -2 and
distribute so that's going to give us
-2X - 2 H we're going to see if we can
combine like terms it looks like we can
just combine these two right here so
it's going to be x^2 plus
2xh + h^ 2 - 2x - 2 H and that's going
to be your output let's go to number
three and four now so three and four it
says evaluate but here you can see
they're giving us what we call a
piecewise function it's in parts and you
want to pay attention to this input does
it satisfy this top equation or this
bottom equation so -2 is that less than
or equal to -2 or is it greater than -2
well -2 that's equal to -2 which tells
us we're going to put it to this top
equation in place of X so that's going
to look like this -2 2 - 4 a Nega * a
negative gives us a
pos4 - - 4 which is 0 for number four F
of 0 is 0 less than -2 no 0 is actually
greater than all the negative numbers so
is 0 greater than2 yes so that tells us
we're going to put it into this bottom
equation in place of X so that's going
to be 3 * 0 + 5 that's 0 + 5 which just
comes out to five and you got it let's
go on to some other examples now you
might want to try and pause the video
and do some of these problems on your
own for practice and then we'll go
through together and you kind of see
where you're at whether you're grasping
these Concepts or maybe you need to do
some more review but let's look at
number five now so this one's asking us
like what is the domain of this function
here this equation here well the first
thing that I would do is I would analyze
it and the two things you want to watch
out for are that you can't take the even
root of a negative number and you can't
divide by zero so those are the two
things that you want to watch out for so
if we look at this denominator we say
well I don't want this denominator to be
zero if I factor it let's see what would
this factor to it would be Min -5 and +
3 if I set these factors equal to
zero and solve see x equals 5 but we
really don't want X to be five because
that would make this zero and 0 *
anything is zero and we don't want that
denominar to be zero right that's
undefined same thing here xal -3 but we
don't want X to be3 because we can't
divide by zero right so that's the first
thing is I would look at the denominator
set it to zero and find out what values
you don't want X to be the thing I would
analyze here is we've got a square root
and whatever's underneath that square
root it has to be zero or positive now
if this was in the denominator of course
it couldn't be zero because we can't
divide by zero but when it's in the
numerator like this it can be zero but
we want it to really be a positive
number we can't take the square root of
a negative number that would be like an
imaginary number so let's go ahead and
take that x- 4 and say that it has to be
greater than or equal to zero add four
to both sides so that means that X has
to be greater than equal to four so
these are like our restrictions now what
I like to do is I like to go to the
number line say here's like uh four so
we know we want it to be greater than or
equal to four but it can equal five so
that means there's like a hole or a
missing point there and we don't want it
to equal -3 which is somewhere way over
here so I'll just make that as an open
circle so when we write our domain in
interval notation we want to work from
low to high or left to right on the
number line and you can see as long as
we're in this interval here and this
interval here
that'll be perfect right we won't have
any issues with taking the square root
of a negative number or dividing by zero
so what I would say for the domain here
is I would say it's from
four to five notice I'm using the
bracket for four because it includes
four I'm using the parentheses for five
because we don't want it to include five
the parentheses is like an open interval
and then I'm going to use a union from
five to postive Infinity now remember
Infinity you can never reach that's
always going to be a parentheses and
again you can see we have have five
listed here twice but it's up to five
not including and then U for Union this
other interval from five to Infinity
again not including five so that would
be your domain in interval notation
right here now for number six i' graph
this but they would probably say you
know graph this on your graphing
calculator and then find the relative
maximum relative minimum find out uh
where the uh function is increasing
where it's decreasing or where it's
constant so let's analyze this when we
think about a relative maximum it's
basically like a high point relative to
the points on either side of it so for
example this is a relative maximum not
an absolute maximum because this graph
goes up higher and higher but relative
to points on either side that's like a
high point okay that's like a top of the
hill sort of scenario so here I would
say the relative maximum is this point
right right here okay the relative
minimum that would be this point right
here see it's like a low point it's the
lowest point relative to points on
either side of it it's where the graph
bends it's kind of like the the valley
here so this would be like our relative
minimum those are the coordinates of
that point now where is the graph
increasing okay when you figure out
increasing and decreasing constant it's
like reading a book from left to right
and you're you're kind of analyzing does
it have sort of like a positive slope
that's increasing does it have sort of
like a negative slope that's decreasing
so you can see this graph's like
increasing then decreasing then
increasing again right the other thing
you want to pay attention to with
increasing decreasing constant is that
we're interested in for what x value
values are the Y values increasing do
you follow that so what that means is
like when I'm going from negative
Infinity over here all the way to where
X is
1.05 the graph is going up up up right
so I would say it's increasing from
negative Infinity to
1.05 and again with increasing
decreasing constant you always want to
write this with parentheses that's an
open interval you don't want to include
this point here because that's where
it's changing from increasing to
decreasing so just remember intervals
where it's increasing decreasing
constant or open intervals or use your
parentheses and then also notice it's
increasing here so that's when the X
values are from
1.05 to positive Infinity what you don't
want to do is you don't want to look at
the Y values like some people will say
oh I'm increasing from negative Infinity
to 5.02 that's talking about the Y
values we're talking about for what x
values are the Y is increasing okay so I
hope that makes sense for decreasing you
can see it's going down to the right
right kind of like a negative slope here
as we read from left to right so it's
decreasing from this x value 1.05 to
this x value positive 1.05 and so that
would be our interval for where it's
decreasing and then where is it constant
that's where it would be horizontal and
there really isn't an interval where
it's horizontal at this point it's just
like a an instantaneous changing of
direction right there just at that so
it's really not constant you'd have to
see something where it's like a
horizontal line at some point so here
we're just going to say not
applicable or none okay for seven and
eight now we're going to talk about
whether functions are even odd or
neither or how do you say that maybe
neither right okay so then what do you
think now there's a little algebraic
test here we can do it's F ofx so if you
replace Negative X in your function and
you get back the original function f ofx
that tells us that it's an even function
what does that mean even it means that
it's a reflection over the Y AIS so for
example this could be one possibility
see if I fold that graph it matches to
itself when it's odd if you put negx in
place of X and you get back that
original function but it's multiplied by
-1 that tells you that it's an odd
function which could potentially look
something like this it's a rotation 180
degre about the origin if you turn that
page uh half turn it'll match to itself
okay if it doesn't fit either of these
then it it would be neither or neither
however you like to say that okay so
here let's go ahead and test it out now
we're going to replace x with X and
again remember when I substitute I like
to put it in parentheses treat it like a
group and then we're going to simplify
now remember a negative to an even power
is going to be positive because negative
four times right is a positive this is
going to become a positive x^2 * a -3 is
- 3x^2 + 1 so what do you notice here
it's the exact same as the original
function that tells us that this is an
even function and you can test yourself
if your teacher lets you use graph and
calcul you could graph this and see if
you fold that graph over the y- axis
does it match to itself if it does then
it's even now for number eight same
thing we're going to do that same
algebraic test we're going to replace x
with netive
X okay so wherever I see X I'm putting
Negative X in parentheses like that a
negative * a negative * a negative five
negatives multiply together would give
us a negative so X to 5th a negative * a
negative is POS x + 1 so now when we
look at this does it match the original
function no if it it did it would be
even let's see if we can factor out a
negative 1 so we factor out a negative 1
all these signs are going to change to
the opposite and what's in parentheses
is this the same as the original
function almost except for this negative
one this is positive one if this was a
positive one if these matched if this
whole function was multiplied by Nega 1
that would tell us that it's an odd
function which means that it's a
rotation 180° about the origin in this
case since it doesn't uh match the
original function * NE 1 this is
actually going to be neither or neither
however you prefer to say that and you
got it let's take a look at some more
examples okay for number nine what I
want you to do if you would please is
describe the order of Transformations
from F ofx = < TK of x to G ofx which is
-2 * the x -1 + 4 now remember the order
is important so you don't want to just
do it in any random order you want to
think about you know what do I do first
second third like that and there's more
than one correct answer one thing you
want to pay attention to when you do
these Transformations is is this
vertical shift this uh quantity here at
the end sometimes referred to as the K
value that always occurs last so in this
case what I like to do is I like to
start from the inside and kind of work
my way out and I would say this minus
one is actually going to shift the graph
right one whatever's a group of the X
remember that has like the opposite
effect if it was plus one it would go
left one so I would say uh
shift
right uh one okay this two here is going
to be a vertical stretch by a factor of
two now the way I like to think about it
is when it's group with the X it's going
to affect the X values left and right
but it has the opposite effect if it's
not group with the X it's going to
affect the Y values and it has the quote
unquote same effect meaning two is
bigger than one that means it's going to
be a stretch if it was between zero and
one it would be like a shrink uh okay
just like you would think so in this
case I would say a vertical stretch I'm
just going to abbreviate a little bit
here vertical stretch uh by a factor of
two factor of of 2 now this negative
it's going to make all the Y values the
opposite you're multiplying all the Y
values by Nega 1 that's going to reflect
it over the x axis so I'm going to say
reflect
over
xaxis and then the plus four that's
going to shift the graph up four now
notice it's not group of the X so that's
affecting the yv values it's shifting it
up four if it was minus 4 it shifted
down four so we'll just say uh
shift up or you can say translate up
four units now you might have said this
slightly differently you might have said
reflect over the xais vertical stretch
by a factor of two shift right one then
shift up four that would be correct also
you could also say uh vertical stretch
by a factor of two then reflect over the
x-axis then shift right one then up four
but notice in all these cases that plus4
is actually going to be occurring last I
have lots of videos about
Transformations you can check those out
if you want to go deeper uh into that
topic number 10
we're given these two functions f ofx
and g ofx and we want to find out what's
a g of f of 5 okay now when you see this
little circle here it's not zero it's
not multiplication it actually means the
composition of functions this you could
rewrite this as G of f of 5 when it's in
this form here you're actually working
from the right to the left just a little
bit counterintuitive for some students
which is why I like to rewrite it in
this notation with the parentheses
because we're used to working for the
most inner parenthesis outward right so
what you would do is you'd start with
your F function whatever is in
parentheses we're going to replace that
with five in this case so 5 - 1 is 4 the
square of 4 is 2 so this whole quantity
here is two now that 2 becomes the input
in our G function so that's going to be
2 * 2^ 2 + 1 2^ 2 is 4 * 2 is 8 + 1 is
99 remember your order of operations
parentheses exponents multiplication
like that now for number 11 this one's a
little bit different this one we have FG
of two now notice these are right next
to each other nothing in between that
means that're they're multiplied
together so you could really think of
this as uh F of 2 * G of 2 this is just
like a condensed way of writing it so if
we go to
our uh F function and we put two in here
2 - 1 is 1 the square of 1 is 1 if we go
to our G function we put two in we we
already figured that out that was nine
right so this comes out to 1 * 99 which
is 9 so you might want to review
composition of functions and then adding
subtracting multiplying and dividing
functions for number 12 now we want to
find the inverse of this function
algebraically now this is a little bit
more challenging question and you'll see
why in just a second but remember the
process for finding the inverse what you
do is you can think of f ofx as like the
Y value and you're switching the X and
the Y wherever you see X you put y
wherever you see y you put X you're just
interchanging the input and the output
okay and what you want to do is you want
to solve for this new yv value you want
to get that by itself so the way I'm
going to do that is I'm going to square
both sides of this equation the square
and the square root cancel one another
out we're going to add four to both
sides and we're going to divide by two
or multiply everything by 1/2 so that
comes out to 12x^2
uh plus 2 is equal to y or instead of Y
let's write it using the inverse
notation f - 1 that means the inverse of
the function f is equal to 12x^2 + 2 now
remember I said this a little bit more
challenging and the reason is and you
can graph this on your graphing
calculator if you want but what's
happening here is that this graph is
looking something like uh this okay
roughly and so what this means see this
is going to be right here at two the
domain is from two to Infinity that's
what the X values can be the range is is
what the yv values can be that's from 0
to Infinity but when you find the
inverse because you're switching the X
and the Y values the domain and the
range switch so the range 0 to Infinity
becomes our domain so I'm going to put a
little restriction here I'm going to say
x has to be greater than or equal to
zero that's the same as 0 to Infinity
now you might be saying Mario why why
are you doing all this right well if you
graph this 12x^2 + 2 see it's a parabola
like this roughly right but when you
find the inverse what you're doing is
you're
finding the reflection of this graph
over the line yal X that's graphically
what it looks like so it look something
like this but you can see this graph
doesn't look like that it's got this
Branch over here how do we get rid of
this Branch well we could erase it with
our finger or we could say let's put a
restriction on here x has to be just the
part greater than or equal to zero and
so that's what you want to do you want
to look at the domain range of the
original function keep in mind that that
that range will become the domain in
your inverse function let's take a look
at some more
examples okay if you get an A on your
pre-cal midterm leave a comment below
and let me know I always like getting
those uh feedback from people when they
they really uh do well on their exams
from these reviews so for 13 it says
show that these two functions are
inverses of each other and we're going
to add algebraically so how do you show
that these are inverses algebraically
that's where you can use the composition
of functions and what you want to do is
you w to
find out what F of G ofx is equal to as
well as G of f ofx you want to compose
the functions both ways and what you
want to get is you want to get X for
your final result so if you get X for
both of those it proves algebraically
that they're undoing one another and so
let's go ahead and do that right now so
F of g ofx means that we're putting the
G function okay which is x + 3/ 2 okay
that's this quantity here into the F
function so whatever is in parenthesis
goes in place of X on the right so this
is going to be 2 * x +
3 uh over 2 - 3 okay notice the twoos
cancel because this is like 2 over one
and we're left with x + 3 - 3 the 3's
cancel and you can see we just uh we
just get X here okay okay great now you
don't want to just do one part your
teacher will Mark you half off you want
to make sure you do both ways so we say
G of f ofx now we're taking the F
function which is 2x -
3 and we're putting it into the G
function in place of X right there so
what I'm going to do is I'm instead of X
I'm going to replace it with 2x -
3 + 3 all divid 2 now -3 and posi3
that's going to be zero and 2x / two the
twos cancel and you can see we get X
which you can see that proves
algebraically that they're inverses
because see what happens is if you put X
into your F function it takes you over
here and then if you put it you take
this output and you put it into the G
function if it takes you back to that
original input X that's showing you that
they're undoing one another okay so I
hope that makes sense so for number 14
now say you're given this graph yal F
ofx right here and we want to sketch y
equals the absolute value of f ofx how
would you do something like that well
when you remember when you think about f
ofx f ofx refers to like the Y values
and so what we're doing is we're taking
the ABS value which always makes that
output positive right so what you're
going to do is you're going to say well
hm these y values over here they're
below the x-axis they're negative when I
take the absolute value that makes them
positive so what that does in effect is
it reflects it over the X axxis these
negative values here become positive the
positive values the absolute value of a
positive is still positive so it's just
this Branch right here that I'm going to
be reflecting so the graph should look
something
like this
okay so you see how I took this branch
and I reflected it okay for number 15 16
and 17 we're working with uh complex
numbers now and you want to see if you
can simplify these we've got 4 - 5 i^
squar how would you simplify that one
well when you square a complex number
you can think about multiplying it by
itself it's like you've got two of that
quantity then what you can do is you can
foil or distribute twice so 4 * 4 is 16
4 * 5 I is -2 I 5 I * 4 is another -2 I
and 5 I * 5 I is posi 25 I 2 now
remember i^2 is equal to -1 I is the
square root of1 so if I replace i s here
with -1 * 25 is -25 + 16 is -9 and if I
combine these together we get -40 I
remember you want to write your answer
in the standard form of a complex number
A plus b I you want the real first and
the imaginary second now for number 16
this is 1 over 2 + I we don't want that
I in the denominator it's considered
improper so what we want to do here is
we're going to multiply by the complex
conjugate what's the complex conjugate
it's the same quantity here but we're
changing the sign in between to the
opposite if this was 2 minus I I'd
multiply by 2 plus I you don't want to
change both signs you don't want to make
this a -2 minus I you just want want to
change the sign in between of course
whatever you do to the denominator you
have to do to the numerator because
that's like multiplying by the number
one so it's not going to change the
value it's just going to change the way
that this looks so we get 2 - I and here
we get 2 * 2 which is uh
4 uh this gives us -2 I positive 2 I you
can see those cancel and then we get I
2ar now remember i^2 is -1 * this
negative is a positive 1 plus this four
is 5 so so this is coming out to 2 - I
over 5 you don't want to leave it like
this you want to split this up into the
real part which is 2
fths minus the 1 I so it's in the
standard form real plus imaginary the a
plus bi I form and then for 17 we have I
to the 35th power the way I like to
simplify these is I say how many times
does two go into 35 that's 17 times with
one left over right the reason I do that
is because i^2
is1 okay and a negative to an odd power
would be negative one right and then
times I so we get negative I so what
we're doing is we're making use of the
rules of exponents power to a power you
multiply so that's 34 and when you
multiply and you have the same base you
add 34 + 1 is
35 now what some students like to do is
they like to remember that I to the 1 is
i i to the 2 is - 1 I to the 3 is
negative I and I to the 4th is 1 and
then it repeats 5 6 7 8 Etc so we'd say
four goes into 35 eight times with three
left over 1 2 3 see how we're getting
negative I the same thing I like to just
use this method it's a little bit less
to remember but some people like this
method so pick whichever is uh easiest
for you and let's keep going with some
more examples I hope this is helping
okay for number 18 we want to solve this
equation so how would you do that one
there's a couple different options you
could try to get everything on one side
and set it to zero and Factor you could
try to uh graph it and find out where it
crosses x- axis once you set the SQL to
zero and find those zeros you could do
the quadratic formula you could uh do
the completing the square there's a lot
of different methods and this one I'm
going to do the completing the square so
what I'm going to do is I'm going to
take half of this B value and square it
so half of ne8
is-4 -42 is 16 but if I add 16 to the
left side I have to add 16 to the right
side to keep it balanced right okay now
the reason we do that we take half of b^
squ is to make this a perfect square
trinomial which we can then Factor as a
binomial squared it'll always be half of
this B value if it was plus 8X this
would be plus4 now we have a perfect
square here we can solve by taking the
square root of both sides remember when
you take the square root of both sides
you get two answers plus or minus the
square and the square root cancel and if
I add four to both sides we get x = 4
plus or minus thek of 31 now if it's up
to you and you can do any method a lot
of people just like to
get everything on one side set it to
zero and do the quadratic formula so you
might want to do that method if you are
not forced to use a uh completing the
square method now for number 19 it says
if three is a zero of the function find
out what c is now there's a couple
different ways to do this but they're
testing us on do we know what a zero is
like what does that even mean well it
means that if we were to put three in
for X the output will equal zero okay so
what we could do is we could just put
put three in for x and set this equation
to zero and solve for C that's a good
way to do it you can also make use of
synthetic division here so we could say
well hm if three is a zero our
coefficients are 1 x 4th 0x cubed -2X
SAR 0x and c and what I'm going to do is
I'm going to bring down that one
multiply in the diagonal add straight
down multiply in the diagonal add
straight down multiply in the diagonal
add straight down multiply the diagonal
add straight down but I want this to
come out to zero okay so that means that
C +
63 has to equal zero and if I subtract
63 you can see that c must equal -63
this is sometimes referred to as the
synthetic substitution method or the
remainder theorem but what we're doing
is this is the input this is the output
we want that output to be zero if three
is to be a zero remember what a zero is
it's saying at three this graph crosses
the x-axis there at three now for number
20 it says two solutions of this
equation are 1 and -4 how do we find the
remaining Solutions it's very similar to
this problem in the sense that if one is
a solution meaning it equals zero okay
uh so that one is called a zero that
means that we can do our synthetic
substitution here and it's going to
bring it down from X to 4th to X the 3r
so it's going to bring it down by one
degree okay so let's go ahead and do the
synthetic so we're going to bring down
the one multiply in the diagonal add
straight down multiplying the diagonal
add straight down multiplying the
diagonal add straight down multiplying
the diagonal add straight down and we
got zero which is what we were
anticipating since one makes this
equation equal to zero but we also
negative know that4 is a solution so
we're going to do the synthetic division
again on what's left here okay so we're
going to bring down the one multiplying
the diagonal add straight down
multiplying the diagonal add straight
down multiplying the diagonal add
straight down again we're getting zero
which is what we expected because we
know that -4 is a zero or a solution and
we went from X to 4th to X the 3r to X
the 2 so this is 1 x^2 + 0x + 9 and if I
set that equal to zero and solve we're
going to subtract nine from both sides
take the square root of both sides
remember when you take the square root
you get two answers plus or minus square
of 9 is 3 S 1 is I so we're getting plus
or minus 3 I for our remaining two
solutions let's go to some more examples
okay for number 21 see if you can do
this problem it says find the zeros of
this function 2x Cub - 7 x^2 - 17x + 10
using the Rational root theorem now
depending on your teacher and how your
midterm is set up you know you might be
part of the test might be calculator
part of the test might be no calculator
but if you could use your calculator you
could of course graph it and see where
it crosses the x-axis those are the
zeros but if you can't use a calculator
we can use What's called the rational
root theorem where we take all the
factors of the constant plus or minus so
everything that goes into 10 positive or
negative divided by all the factors of
the leading
coefficient sometimes refer this as like
P over Q so it could be any numerator
with any denominator so it could be one
it could be 1/2 it could be two it could
be uh two over two which is one or five
five any positive or negative so there's
a lot of combinations but this is
supposed to narrow it down what we're
going to do now is we're going to use
synthetic division
to uh narrow down our choices so uh or
we're going to try to find out which one
of these works now I can show you just
maybe what I normally do which just
start with one and two and just smaller
numbers integer numbers and test them
out but in the interest of time in this
video I'm just going to say that I got
to let's say -2 and you can see that's
two over one I'm just using -2 here and
we're going to do our synthetic division
remember if there's any missing terms
you want to make sure you put a
placeholder a zero and let's go ahead
and do that that synthetic division so
bring down the first number multiply in
the diagonal add straight down multiply
in the diagonal add straight down
multiply on the
diagonal this is a positive five okay
and we get zero remainder okay so that
tells us that Nega -2 is a zero but what
it also does is it brings it down from X
cubed to X2 so now we have 2x2 - 11x + 5
we can then factor that or do the
quadratic formula
to find the remaining zero so let's see
if we can Factor this this is going to
be like this and if we set these factors
to zero we're going to get x = 12 x is
equal to 5 and we also got X is equal to
-2 so those are the zeros that's where
the graph crosses the x-axis again the
rational root theorem just Narrows down
our choices but we have to do some
synthetic division to bring it down to a
quadratic where we could then factor to
do the quadratic formula sometimes you
could even Factor it at this stage here
and set those those factors to zero it's
just that this one wasn't factorable uh
easily so let's look at number 22 now
let's say you want to graph this
function now it's already in factored
form we want to draw like a sketch it
doesn't have to be perfect but we want
to draw a sketch paying attention to the
N Behavior the zeros and the shape of
the graph at those X intercepts so how
do we do that well we can set these
factors to zero we can see that this is
going to
be1 with multiplicity two what happens
when you have a multiplicity of two or
an even multiplicity is the graph's
going to bounce off that point it's
going to kind of look like a parabola
shape it's going to kind of bounce off
that point now here we set this group uh
equal to zero this factor to zero it's
going to cross here at five uh but
that's with multiplicity three that's a
triple zero now when it has a triple
zero uh or you could say an odd
multiplicity it's going to go through
that point that x intercept but if you
want to make it a little bit more
accurate you can kind of give it like a
cubic type shape okay if you know what
yal x Cub looks like and we also also
know that it's going to cross here at4
if we set this Factor equal to zero 1 2
3 4 right here now as far as the end
behavior if we look at that leading
coefficient negative the leading
coefficient tells us if it's positive it
goes up to the right if it's negative it
goes down to the right and the degree if
we were to multiply this out which we
don't have to we can just add these
exponents 1+ 3 plus 2 which is six if
it's an even degree the right end
behavior and the left end behavior are
going to be the same they either going
to both be down or both be up if it's an
odd degree then they're going to go
opposite direction so odd degree now
let's see what happens here so at -4 it
just occurs once when it's an odd
multiplicity it's going to go through
kind of like a line at negative one we
said this at a multiplicity of two
that's going to have like a parabola
shape it's going to basically bounce if
it was coming from this direction it
would bounce this way and then at five
it has a multiplicity of
three which we can embellish a little
bit here by giving it kind of like a
cubic shape see that x cubed if it was
coming from this direction it would look
kind of like like yal X cubed that gives
us a pretty good sketch if you uh had
let's say a fifth degree it would have
the same kind of shape if you want to
find the Y intercept you could put zero
in for X to find the Y intercept but
this is a pretty good sketch okay for
number 23 Now find a polinomial equation
with integer coefficients and the Zer 2
- 3i and one now what's interesting here
is we want this polom to have in
coefficients which means if one of the
zeros is uh complex it has to have its
complex conjugate also as a zero so that
means that if one is a zero x minus one
is what we call a factor the factor is
always x minus the zero and here we have
x - 2 - 3 I and we would also have x - 2
+ 3 I see how these are conjugates of
one another they go together as a pair
when the coefficients of the polinomial
are integers now what I would do is I
would distribute this negative here
let's kind of simplify this a little
bit distribute this
negative and I'll show you a little
trick this kind of makes it a little bit
easier see these xus 2s I'm going to
group those together and what happens we
have a sum and difference pattern you
probably remember like a plus b * a
minus B multiplies to a^2 minus b ^ 2
and that's what's going to happen here
we're going to have x - 2 * x - 2 which
is x^2 - 4x + 4 if you multiply that out
the inside 3 I * x - 2 and - 3 I * x -2
those are opposites they cancel and then
3 I * -3 I is -9 i^ 2 i s is-1 * -9 is a
positive 9 so this really comes out to
13 I'll just cross it out let's make
that 13 so now we have x -1 * x^2 - 4x +
13 we just have to to multiply that out
so if I multiply x * all of these we're
going to get X Cub -
4x^2 uh + 13x and If I multiply
everything by-1 that's going to give us
x^2 uh + 4x -3 and if we add that
together I'm running out of space I'll
put it over here we've got X cubed -
5x^2 -
5x^2 uh + 17x -3
and I'd probably write this as f ofx is
equal to and there's our polinomial
function with integer coefficients you
don't see like an I here or 17i and
that's because these zeros these complex
zeros came as conjugate pairs let's do
some more examples okay for number 24
and 25 we're going to do some graphing
so for 24 notice we have this pie wise
function how do we graph it there's a
couple different methods one method is
you could graph the entire uh equation
and then erase the part that you don't
want the other method that a lot of
students like is where you can make a
table and we're going to make two tables
for each equation here so we're going to
graph y = x + 2 when X is less than or
equal to Zer so I'm going to pick Z or
numbers that are less than zero and if
we put zero in we're going to get two if
we put Nega - 1 in we get three if we
put -2 in we get four so if I plot that
I'm going to get 02 which is right here
now notice when it's equal to we want to
make it a closed Circle if it's less
than or greater than it's going to be
hollower an open circle - 1 is 3 and -2
is 4 and less than or equal to zero
means to the left here so less than is
to the left so you can see this graph
goes like that of course if we graph the
whole line it would go like that we just
want this part now we're going to graph
y = 2x^2 when X is greater than zero now
if you're using the table method you're
going to want to pick zero as well even
though it says X is greater than zero
but we're just going to graph this as an
open or a Hollow Circle okay so 0 1 2 so
that's going to give us 0 2 and 8 okay
so now if we plot these points 0 0 this
is going to be open uh one two is going
to be right here and 28 is somewhere up
here so this graph is basically going
like this it's like half of a parabola
right now notice it's still a function
because it passes that vertical line
test see this is open this is closed but
it's in parts or pieces and we could
even have a third piece fourth piece Etc
this one just had two parts okay for
number 25 now we're graphing this
rational function notice it's a ratio of
a polinomial divided by a polinomial how
do we get a good sketch the first thing
I like to do is I like to factor as much
as I can numerator and denominator now
the reason we do that this is a
difference of two squares x + 3 xus 3 is
to see if there's any factors that
cancel numerator and denominator in this
case the xus 3 is cancel that tells us
there's going to be a hole in the graph
at x equals 3 so if I set this to zero I
get three now if I put three into what's
left over I get 3 over 6 which is2 so at
3 comma 12 there's going to be an open
like a missing point there removable
discontinuity or a
hole now the other thing I want to do is
I want to make sure that the denominator
doesn't equal zero so here if x equals
-3 that's going to give us a vertical
ASM toote at -3 x = -3 now when the
degree in the denominator is higher than
the degree in the numerator see how this
is second degree this is first degree
our horizontal ASM toote is going to be
right on the x-axis is going to be the
line Y equals 0 so I'll just draw that
as a dash or dotted line Y equals
0 now we can make a table we can find
the X and Y intercepts those are some
other key points on our graph by setting
the opposite variable to zero if I put
zero in for X you can see that comes out
to9 over9 which is
one and if I put y equal to zero
okay now let's look at this here for a
minute so Y is 0 so that equals 0 = 3x -
9 over x^2 - 9 or you could use the
reduceed form here uh 3 overx + 3
because you can see the x - 3 is cancel
and what I can do is I can multiply both
sides by x + 3 but x + 3 * 0 is 0 equal
3 which doesn't make any sense so what
does that tell us that tells us that
there's not an X intercept it doesn't
cross the xaxis
so you can see the graph is going to go
like this through these
points okay like that it's good to pick
points on either either side of the
vertical ASM toote because you can't
cross a vertical ASM toote it' be like
dividing by zero so you might want to
try to plug in maybe -4 and -2 to get an
idea if it's going up or if it's going
down as it approaches that ASM toote so
let's just put4 in here that would be -1
3 divided 1 is
-3 uh so that means you're going to be
right over here atg3 so this Branch you
can see kind of looks like this and it's
approaching that horizontal ASM
toote graphing rational uh functions is
a big topic I have a lot of videos on my
Mario's math tutoring uh YouTube channel
if you wanted to dive deeper into this
uh there's a lot about graphing rational
functions there so for number 26 now
we're trying to figure out if this
function has x-axis Y axis or origin
Symmetry algebraically and these are the
algebraic tests now sometimes people get
these a little bit confused with the the
even odd tests remember we put Negative
X in and we see if we get F ofx back or
if we get f ofx * negative 1 back but
this one when you're testing for xaxis
y- axis origin symmetry algebraically
here's the test if you're check checking
for x-axis symmetry you place y with
negative y you can think of f ofx as
like y so we're going to replace this
with negative y replace x with just X so
it's going to stay the same and then I'm
going to multiply both sides by1 if I do
that negative 1 is like- 1 over one
right so this this comes out to Y = X
over x^2 + 1 now does that give us the
original function back here no it's not
the same so that tells us it does not
have x-axis symmetry okay y-axis
symmetry we're going to replace x with
negx Y with positive y so that's going
to look like y
=
x okay and if I simplify we get Y = X
over x^2 + 1 now does this look like the
original function no because see the
negative X so it doesn't have y- AIS
symmetry how about origin replace x with
negative X Y with Nega
y let's see what happens
here now it could be more than one could
be two of them all three of them or none
of them let's just see so if we simplify
we geta * a negative is a positive x * X
is postive x^2 and If I multiply both
sides of the equation by Nega 1 which
remember negative 1 is like 1 over posit
1 uh that's going to give us POS y = x
x^2 + 1 same thing has the original
equation so that tells us that this has
uh origin symmetry meaning if we graph
this it's a 180° turn about the origin
so great job if you're able to follow
these ones I have more of these videos
on my channel if you want more practice
let's keep going with this review okay
for number 27 graph this function and
notice this is a quadratic function a
second degree function how would you
graph that there's a couple different
methods on this particular one what I'm
going to show you is I'm going to factor
out a
-1 so that's going to be x^2 - x - 6 and
then I can Factor this a little bit
further x - 3 x +2 now the reason I did
that when it's in factored form like
this this is called the intercept form
and by setting these factors equal to
zero you can find the x intercept so
it's going to cross here at three and
it's going to cross here at -2 now you
you can find the Axis of Symmetry by
finding the halfway point or by adding
these together and dividing by two so
that's coming to 1/2 so at xal 1/2
that's your Axis of Symmetry and by
putting 1/2 back in for X we can find
the uh y-coordinate of the vertex so
let's go ahead and do that so that comes
out to let's see -1 times let's see this
would be2 - 6es which is
-5 and then this is uh 4
5 halves okay so this comes out to uh
254s which is 6 and 1/4 okay so
basically 1 2 3 4 5 6 and 1/4 is right
about there if we set x equal to zero we
get the Y intercept which is six and we
can reflect that over the uh axis of
symmetry there and we get a pretty good
sketch of our graph again this is called
the intercept form now you can also do
uh the formula xal
B over 2 a so you would take the
opposite of B over 2 * a that would give
you the x coordinate of the vertex and
the axis of symmetry and you could plug
it back in you would get the
y-coordinate different ways to graph but
I just did the intercept form on that
one now for number 28 it says evaluate
which just means find the value of this
expression remember when you multiply
what do you do to the exponents you add
right so this is like e to the 5th and
when you divide what do you do to the
exponents you subtract right this is 9 -
5 is e 4th and then the square root of e
to 4th remember the square root is like
the 1/2 power power to power you
multiply so that just comes out to e squ
now e is our our natural base e or
Oilers number now for number
29 we've got 5 2 - x is equal to 125
there's something called the one: one
property of exponents where you can get
the bases on the same to be uh both
equal to one another so they're both
base five so if the bases are the same
that means the exponents or the powers
have to be the same we could set those
equal to each other and solve so that
comes out tox = 1 divide both sides by
Nega 1 and you can see xal 1 you can
plug it back in and verify number 30 we
have a story problem here it says if a
rare coin is valued currently at
$100 and is increasing in value at 5%
per year what will be the value of the
coin in seven years okay so a formula
you might want to write down or memorize
here would be this one a = p * 1 + r the
T So p is kind of like the starting
amount a is like the ending amount one
is like 100% or the original value R is
your interest rate but as a decimal so
you have to convert that and then T is
the time in years now if this was
decreasing this would be 1 minus r okay
so in this case we can see we're
starting at
$100 it's going up by 5% which is 05 as
a decimal there and the time would be 7
years so I'm going to go to my
calculator here and let's just
evaluate sometimes your teacher will
just have you leave it in calculator
ready form but I'm getting let's see a
is equal to
$14.7 would be the value of the coin in
7 years we're halfway through might want
to take a little breather but let's see
if we can finish this review and get you
a good grade on your pre-cal uh
midterm okay for question number 31 we
have how long will it take $500 to
double at a 7% annual interest rate
compounded continuously and the key
phrase here is this compounded
continuously so how would you do that
problem well if I was going to do it I
would remember the formula a equal p to
the RT this is the formula you use when
you're compounding continuously e is our
natural base e
2.7 and it looks like we're starting
with 500 so that's our P or our
principle what we're putting in and
since it's going to double that means
what comes out a is going to be a th
interest rate is 7% so that's 07 as a
decimal and the t is the time that's
what we're trying to solve for the
number of years so what I would do is I
would divide both sides by 500 that's
going to give us 2 = uh e to
07t then I would take the natural log or
the Ln of both sides because remember
natural log is log base e and the log
base e and the exponential function base
e those are inverses of one another they
undo each other or cancel each other out
and then to get uh T by itself we'll
just divide both sides by
07 and our time is let's see we'll do it
on the calculator this is an exact
answer but if you want to get an
approximation it's coming out to about
9.9 uh approximately 9.9
years and we got it okay for number 32
this one we've got log of 3 = a and log
of 2 is equal to B How would you find
log of 8 99th in terms of A and B so
what this problem is talking about is
knowing how to expand and condense
logarithms so knowing the properties of
logarithms what I would do here is since
we're dividing remember when you divide
you can write it as a difference of two
logs and when I notice here this this
eight is actually like uh 2 to the 3
power and this 9 here is really like 3
to the 2 power then what we can do is we
can use the power property to bring the
these Powers down in front of the logs
and multiply it by the log so this would
really be like 3 * log of 2 - 2 * log of
3 but what is log of two equal to that's
B so this would be 3 B minus what's log
of 3 equal to that's a so minus 2 a and
now we've written it in terms of A and B
okay for 33 and 34 how would you
simplify these logarithms here well what
you can do a lot of students like to do
this is just to set it equal to like a
variable like X and what you can do is
you can rewrite this in exponential form
by quote unquote exponentiating or
raising both uh sides using base three
because exponential functions and
logarithmic functions are inverses of
each other as long as those bases are
the same so now we have S > 27 is equal
to 3 to the X power but we know that 27
is uh 3 cubed and this square root is
like the index is two so this is really
like 3 to the 3es power is equal to 3 to
the X now if we have the bases the same
that means the exponents are equal so X
would just equal 3 halves and you got it
now for number 34 this one's a little
bit different because see how this base
is two and this log base is three so
they don't match so we can't just go
ahead and cancel those out like we did
over in that other example but what we
can do is we can look at this log base 3
of 81 log base 3 of 81 is really what
well 81 is like 3 to 4th power so we can
see the log base 3 and exponential
function base 3 those are inverses so
this whole quantity right here just
comes out to four so we have 2 4th power
which is equal to 2 * 2 * 2 * 2 that's
16 and you got it let's do some more
examples for number 35 how would you
expand this using the properties of
logarithms write it as a sum and
difference of logs in this case we were
dealing with a natural log and so you
can see here that we've got the fifth
root of x^2 over y cubed you could
rewrite this a little bit just to make
it a little bit easier this is really
like uh x to the 2s power over y to the
3s power remember the index uh or the
root goes in the denominator and the
power or the exponent goes in the
numerator when you have write it as a
rational exponent but remember when you
divide what do you do you write it as a
difference so you would say natural log
of x to the 25ths minus
natural log of Y to the 3 and then what
we can do is we can use the power
property of logs to bring that power
down in front of the log so this would
be like 2 FS * the natural log of xus 3
fths * the natural log of Y and that's
fully expanded you could check your work
by doing the condensing properties and
you'll get back the original now for
number 36 how would you solve this
logarithmic
equation well you can see these are both
log base 3 and subtracting so we could
combine these into one log by dividing
the arguments so we could say log base 3
of x -1 over x + 2 is equal to 1 then
what I would do is I would rewrite it in
the exponential form or you can do this
technique where you like exponentiate
both sides using the same base as the
log since these are inverses and now
what we have is x - one over x + 2 is
equal to 3 Let's multiply both sides by
x + 2
and we get X - 1 is = 3x + 6 let's
subtract X from both sides and let's
subtract six from both sides and so we
get let's see -7 is equal to 2x / uh 2
so X is equal to
-7 now one thing you want to be careful
of when you solve these log equations
you want to put this back in to make
sure that we're not taking the log of
zero or negative quantity if we are then
it's going to be an extraneous solution
which is what happens here we're getting
a negative number so there's really no
solution uh to this equation now for 37
we're solving this exponential equation
how would you solve for x on this one
well I'd work from the outside in
towards that X by doing the opposite so
I'd add one to both sides so that comes
out to 11 and then now because that
variable is in the exponent position I
need to get it down from there by
rewriting this in the logarithmic form
so what you could do is you could just
like take the log base 4 of both sides
of this
equation keeping it balanced and you can
see the log base 4 and the exponential
function base 4 those are inverses of
one another and then now all we have to
do is divide both sides by
two and this is like an exact answer
here you could leave it like that or you
could get a decimal approximation here
I'll give you a decimal approximation in
case you want to uh check my work here
let's see so let's do this here
um okay all right so I'm getting
approximately uh
865 if you round to the uh to the
thousands place let's take a look at
some more examples okay for number 38
how would you solve this log equation
well if I was going to do it I would
rewrite this in the exponential form by
exponentiating both sides using the same
base two these are inverses of one
another they cancel one another out and
we have 8 2 is equal to 2 x power now
what I notice is that we've got a lot of
twos here right so this eight is really
like 2 the 3 power square of two is like
2 to the2 power and then remember when
you multiply and you have the same base
you add the exponents so that's going to
be 6es + 1 12 is 7 Hales and now we have
the one to one property of exponents if
the bases are the same that means that
the uh exponents will be the same so you
can see that X is going to come out to 7
halves for number 39 we've got a
logarithmic equation and notice that we
have the same base on both sides here
log base 5 log base 5 this is called the
one: one property of logs here you can
just set the arguments equal to each
other and solve so this comes out to x +
1 is equal to 2x - 3 Let's subtract X
from both sides and let's add three to
both sides so that comes out to X is
equal to 4 now you want to check when
you have these logarithmic equations you
plug it back in make sure this whole
argument is positive it comes out to
zero or negative then it's like a false
answer or extraneous so it looks like
these are both coming out to a positive
number so four is a good answer now for
number 40 how would you solve this
equation E 2x - e x - 2 =
0 well if I was going to do this one we
could Factor it we could Factor it as e
to x * e to the X which remember that's
when you multiply you add so that's e 2x
what two numbers multiply to -2 but add
to that middle coefficient of -1 that
would be -2 and
pos1 and now that we have it factored we
can set each of these groups or each of
these factors equal to zero and solve so
we have e to x - 2 = 0 e x + 1 = 0 Let's
add two to both sides subtract one from
both sides and then what we're going to
do is we're going to take the natural
log of both sides
and the reason being is because natural
log is log base e so the log base e and
the exponential function base e those
are inverses they undo one another so
we're getting X is equal to the natural
log of
2 or X is equal to the natural log of -1
but we can't take the log or the natural
log of zero or a negative number so this
one's actually like an extraneous root
or extraneous solution so we're just
getting one answer here just natural log
of two okay now for 41 and 42 let's find
the arc length and the area of this
sector here so the Arc Length what's
this length right here and what's the
area of this like pizza slice this piie
slice you can do this problem a couple
different ways I'm going to show you uh
couple formulas here just to kind of
refresh you s equal R Theta and area of
the sector equals 12 R2 Theta the only
thing is to use these two formulas Theta
the central angle here has to be in
radians so remember how to convert from
uh degrees to radians you can multiply
by pi over 180 see how the degrees
cancels numerator and denominator so you
get 120 pi over
180 which reduces down to 2 pi over 3
now you probably knew that already from
the unit circle but just to refresh so s
represents the Arc Length our radius is
in and our uh central angle is 2 pi over
3 four is like 4 over 1 if we multiply
across we get 8 piun over 3 in and
that's an exact answer for this Arc
Length here this curved portion now if
we want to find the area of the sector
same idea here want to make sure Theta
is in radians we're going to take our
radius squared so 4 squar and then uh
the central angle 2 pi over
3 and sometimes what's helpful is just
to put this over one this way have all
the numerators all the denominators kind
of lining up so this would come out to
one2 * 16 over 1 * 2 piun over 3 this
two and this to cancel out numerator and
denominator if we multiply horizontally
across we get 16 piun over 3 in squared
and that's the area of this sector right
here now you might be saying Mario
couldn't I do this another way using
degrees and you could you could say like
this is
120 ID 360 which is like 13 of the whole
circumference the circumference is 2 pi
r and if you multiply that out you're
going to get the same answer you can
also do the same thing with the area of
a sector you could say
1/3 of Pi R
2 uh cuz the area of a circle is p piun
r^ s but this is 1/3 of the whole circle
and you can get the same answer that way
let's keep going with this review okay
for number 43 and 44 we want to find the
angular speed and the linear speed when
you have a 3-ft diameter wheel that
turns at 100 revolutions per minute so
let's start with the angular speed so
how do we find angular speed well we can
start with what they're giving us which
is 100
revolutions per 1 minute and we want to
get to radians per minute so every one
revolution that represents one rotation
like 2 pi radians so 2 pi radians and
that's per one rev and then notice the
Revolutions in the denominator and the
numerator cancel so we have radians left
over and per minute so we've got it so
all we have to do is multiply across
here so we get 200 pi
radians uh per one
minute okay so that's our angular speed
that's the angle that it turns through
per unit time linear speed we want to
find in miles per hour so we can again
start with 100 uh revs per minute so 100
revolutions per 1
minute and for every one
revolution it basically goes around like
one circumference right and the
circumference we know is pi times
diameter so that's going to be 3 pi
feet for every one revolution now the
revolutions cancel numerator and
denominator we've got feet per minute we
want to convert that to miles per hour
so we know that there's uh
5,280 ft in one mile so you can see the
feet cancel with the feet we have miles
now and we know there's 60 Minutes in 1
hour so 60 minutes per one hour and you
know I know how to set this up because I
want the units to cancel out and be left
with units that we do want right so we
have miles per hour or miles divided by
hours so if we multiply all the
numerators all the denominators and
divide and I'm going to use 3.14 or just
use the pi key on here and we're going
to get an approximation so this is 100 *
3 * pi * 60 all divided by
5,280 so that's coming out to about
10.71 miles per hour so that's the
distance that it's traveling if it was
to go in a straight line instead of a
circle right okay now we're going to do
some unit circle type problems here
we're going to 45 through number 50
we're going to work with the unit circle
we're going to find out exact values for
the S of 7 pi over 6 what would that be
well you can do this a couple different
ways you can memorize the whole unit
circle or you can memorize just the 30
45 and 60 reference angles in the first
quadrant uh let's take a look so 7 piun
over 6 this is like 1
16 Pi 1 Pi is like 180° plus another 1
16 of Pi is going to put us right about
here now you see that reference angle
between the uh terminal Ray and the
x-axis that's pi/ 6 or 30° so it's going
to have the same coordinates here as
here except for in the third
quadrant the X and Y are both negative
now we know on the unit circle the sign
is the y coordinate that's going to be
-2 and you got it so let's look at
number 46 the cosine of 11 pi over 4
four goes into 11 two times with three
left over so this is like 2 and 3/4 PI
so 1 Pi is 180 2 pi 3/4 of Pi is going
to put us right about here drop a
perpendicular to the x-axis and this
reference angle here is another 1/4 Pi
or pi over 4 which is 45° so we're going
to have the same coordinates as our
reference angle in the first quadrant
except for the x is going to be negative
since we're going left the Y is going to
be positive since we're going up and our
cosine is the x coordinate so that's
going to be < tk2 over2 x coordinate on
the unit circle okay for number 47 how
would you do this one tangent of8 pi
over 3 now notice this is a negative
angle positive angles we go
counterclockwise negative angles we go
clockwise this is like 2 and 2/3 so it's
like 1 Pi -2 Pi 23 would put us right
about here
drop a perpendicular to the x-axis and
this reference angle is another 1/3 Pi
which is pi over 3 or 60° again we're in
the third
quadrant so both the X and the y
coordinate are negative and remember the
tangent is the Y / by the X so < tk3
over2 okay < tk3 over2 / -2 remember
when you divide by a fraction it's like
multiplying by the reciprocal so the
twoos can cancel and we just get <
tk3 okay for 48 how would you do that
one secant of 7 Pi so we've got 1 Pi 2
pi 3 Pi 4 Pi 5 Pi 6 Pi 7 Pi this point
right here is -1 comma 0 remember the
secant is the reciprocal of the cosine
the cosine is the x coordinate anything
can be written as a fraction by putting
it over one and if we take the
reciprocal of that negative one we still
get negative
1 okay now the cosecant of 3 pi over 4 3
Pi over4 is right here we did that in an
earlier problem but remember the
cosecant is the reciprocal of the sign
the S is the y-coordinate cosecant is
the reciprocal of that y-coordinate so
if I flip that over that's 2 over > two
we don't want that radical in the
denominator so we can rationalize by
multiplying by < tk2 over < tk2 so this
comes out to 2 < tk2 overk 4 which is
just two and now the twoos cancel so
we're just getting Square < TK of
two okay and the last one uh here for
the unit circle problems number 50
cotangent ofun over 4 remember negative
we're going clockwise it's going to put
us right here this is a pi over 4 or 45
degree reference angle same as this one
here except for now the y coordinate is
going to be negative because we're going
right and down in the fourth quadrant
and remember cotangent is the x / the Y
of course anything divided by itself is
one a positive by negative is a negative
one and you got it so let's take a look
we've got 10 more examples to go hang in
there let's see if we can get through
this review together okay for number 51
52 and 53 we're simplifying these uh
trigonometric Expressions see if you can
do these on your own let's start with 51
we've got cosine of x / 1 - sin^2 of X
and your teacher might provide you with
some of the uh identities the trig
identities but you also might have to
memorize them so sin^2 X Plus Co sin s x
remember what that that equals that's
equal to one that's your basic
Pythagorean trig identity and you can
see that if I was to subtract Sin squ
from both sides here we're going to get
cine SAR is equal to 1 - sin 2 so I can
replace 1us sin s with what it equals
which is cosine squar so now we have
cosine of x over cosine s of x one of
these cosin in the numerator cancels one
of these cosin in the denominator
leaving us with 1 / cosine of x which is
equal to the secant of X and we've
simplified it or condensed as much as we
can for number 52 now how would you
simplify this one whenever I see one uh
trig functions that are to the second
power I think of the Pythagorean trig
identities it doesn't always apply but a
lot of times it does so we know that uh
1 + Cent SAR is equal to cose s and that
means cang squ is equal
to cosecant s minus 1 so I could replace
cotangent squ in the numerator with what
it's equal to cose 2 X -
1 okay now what I notice is this is a
difference of two perfect squares we can
Factor it in a sum and difference
pattern we can say cose of x + 1 and
cosecant of x minus
one and notice the co x + 1 cancels with
the numerator and denominator there
leaving us with just cose x -1
-1 which is equal to cose x - 2 and you
simplified as much as you can now 53
what would you do on this one well I
notice that I've got signs and cosiness
but I have this cotangent here cotangent
is equal to cosine of x over sin of X
and so what happens is See the s of X is
like s of X over 1 numerator and
denominator those
cancel and so we're left with cosine
minus cosine which is just equal to zero
okay for number 54 we have the tangent
of theta is equal
tok3 how can we solve this equation for
Theta in degrees and radians from 0 to
360 and 0 to 2 pi see if you can do that
problem well there's a couple different
ways to look at this but let's look at
the unit circle for a minute we know the
uh 30 45 and 60° reference angles right
and we know that tangent is the Y / the
X on the unit circle so we're asking
ourselves where is the Y / X = to < tk3
well see over here at the pi over 3
angle this is uh 12 comma < tk3 over2
and when I do < tk3 over2 id2 I get <
tk3 but tangent going to be negative in
the second and the fourth quadrant
because in the second quadrant X is Y is
positive in the fourth quadrant X is
positive Y is negative but we have that
pi over 3 or 60° reference angle so we
just have to draw that in the second uh
quadrant as well as in the fourth
quadrant and so over here this is going
to be 2 pi over
3 and over here this is going to be 5 Pi
over3 so those are our answers in
radians or we can say
120° and this is
300° okay so for number 55
uh the sun is at an angle of elevation
of 70° and cast a shadow from a
telephone pole that is 10 ft long how
tall is the pole so we can draw a little
diagram here here's the sun here's the
shadow angle of elevation is uh when
you're looking up you're elevating
you're looking up to the uh sun right
here and here's our telephone pole right
here and the shadow they say is 10 ft
long and we want to find the height so
how would you do that one we know the
angle of elevation is 7
what trig function ties together this
angle this side and this side well
that's going to be opposite and adjacent
which is tangent so we have the tangent
of 70° is equal to opposite over
adjacent all we have to do now is
multiply both sides by 10 and the height
is 10 * the tangent of 70 now you want
to make sure uh if you're doing this on
your calculator that your mode is in
degrees and let's see what that comes
out
to it's about 27
.5
ft okay now for number 56 we're given
that the S of theta equal -23 and the
cosine of theta is greater than zero
meaning positive how could we find the
value of these six trig functions well
one way to look at this is just to think
about okay what quadrant is s negative
in and cosine positive in well cosin's
positive here and here sign's negative
here and here see how they overlap in
the fourth quadrant and we know that s
is the opposite over the hypotenuse and
if we do the Pythagorean theorem let's
see we've got
a^2 plus b^2 which is 4 is equal to c^2
which is 9 so if I subtract four a s is
equal to 5 and if I take the square root
a would equal the square < TK of 5 so
I'm finding that missing side of that
triangle so now when I do the sign we
already they already gave us that that's
Nega
23 the cosecant is the reciprocal so
that's -3 over2 the cosine is adjacent
over hypotenuse so that's going to beunk
5 over 3 the secant is a reciprocal
that's 3 overun 5 we have to rationalize
that because we don't want the radical
in the denominator so that' be 3un 5
over 5 the tangent we know is opposite
over adjacent now I'm using the central
angle here so opposite over adjacent so
-2 overun 5 cotangent a reciprocal so
that' beunk 5 over
-2 this one we have to rationalize
because we don't want that radical the
denominator so this would be --2k 5 over
5 and you got it let's take a look at a
few more examples okay for number 57 we
have the point -7 comma 24 is on the
terminal side of an angle in standard
position find all these values of these
trig functions here well let's see so -7
means we're going left seven up 24 so we
left seven up
24 and the terminal side of the angle
that's means like where the angle
terminates or stops if we do the
Pythagorean theorem uh we get 25 for
that hypotenuse this is a 72425
Pythagorean
triple you can also do Pythagorean
theorem a s + b s = c^2 and solve for
side C now from the central angle here s
is opposite over hypotenuse so that's
going to be 24 over 25 cosecant is the
reciprocal cosine is adjacent over
hypotenuse which is -7 over 25 and the
see is the
reciprocal and the tangent we know is
oppos or adjacent so -47 and the
cotangent is a reciprocal so -7 24 keep
in mind the hypotenuse is always
positive and when you go left that's
negative right that's positive up is
positive down is negative okay for
number 58 we want to graph this sign
function here first thing I would do is
I would find the period the period is
equal to 2 piun / B now what's B well
you see this is in the form y = a a sin
B x - H + K that's kind of like the
general form so this number that comes
just in front of the X to the left of
the X that's our B value so this is
going to be 2 Pi /
2 which is equal to 1 Pi so that's our
period it completes one cycle in one
Pi so let's label that right there now
if I divide that by four our scale here
we're counting by pi over 4 2 pi over 4
which is Pi / 2 3 pi over 4 4 pi over
4 the plus one shifts the graph up one
that's our K value so everything's going
to shift up one we could think of this
kind of like as our new midline or kind
of like our new xaxis it's not shifting
left or right there's not a phase shift
there's not an H value and the three is
like the amplitude that's like our
vertical stretch now it's helpful to
know the basic shape of the sign and the
cosine graph s graph looks like this it
starts at the midline goes to the
maximum back to the midline minimum back
to the midline
so in this case uh we're starting right
here uh we can say we're this is has an
amplitude of three so we're going to be
going start here at the midline we go up
three back to the midline down three so
one two three would put us right here
back to the midline and that completes
one period or one cycle of your s graph
of course it keeps repeating in both
directions now I have more videos on my
Mario's math Tut YouTube channel going
into more depth about how to graph these
trig functions if you need more help
check out those videos let's do two more
examples talking about graphing these
Tri n see if you can graph this uh
cosine function y = -2 cosine 12x - piun
- 2 so there's a lot going on there what
I would do is I would start by finding
the period which remember the period is
2 Pi / B in this case the B
is2 uh so 2 Pi / 12 when you divide by a
fraction it's like multiplying by the
reciprocal so that's going to give us a
period of 4 pi
so there's 4 pi and we can divide this
up into four pieces by dividing by four
so our scale is 1 Pi 2 pi 3 Pi 4 PI
right now the minus two we know this is
going to shift the graph down too so
we're going to think of this kind of
like as our new midline right
here and let me just erase this to make
a little bit more
room because we might need the room
here okay and we can see that the
amplitude is two that's like our
vertical stretch but it also has this
negative which is uh reflecting the
graph and we have this minus Pi which is
Shifting the graph right Pi so what I
would do in this case I would think
about shifting right pi and down two
okay we can think of this as kind of
like our new starting point so this is
kind of like our new uh Y axis this is
kind of like our new x axis this is
going to be like our starting point now
we just have to graph y = -2 cosine
12x uh the cosine graph you want to
memorize this basic shape cosine starts
at the maximum
zero minimum zero maximum that's the
basic shape but it's negative which
means it's going to reflect over that
midline over that xaxis it should look
like this now so what we're going to do
since the amplitude is two we're going
to go
down two okay we're going to start right
here we're going to go up to the
midline up to the maximum which is up to
right here back to the
midline 5 pi over here and then back to
the minimum which should be right about
here so the graph looks something like
this and it keeps repeating okay so for
number 60 we're graphing the tangent
graph here and for tangent and cotangent
the period is just 1 Pi so we can use
the Formula 1 Pi / B to find the period
so this is our B value so we have Pi /
Pi / 2 which is equal to 2 now what I do
with the tangent you want to memorize
the basic shape of the tangent graph it
looks like this where half the graph is
to the left of the Y AIS and half is to
the right so it's kind of like on both
sides there so if I take the period two
and cut it in half at negative 1 and at
positive one that's where our vertical
ASM tootes are going to be and if we cut
that in half again half of one is a half
and half of negative 1 is negative a
half those are like our Midway points
and what this three does it's like a
vertical stretch by three so at these
Midway points normally you're here at
one and at negative 1 but now we're
going to be up here at three and down
here at -3 and it goes right through the
origin so our graph looks something like
like this where it approaches the asmp
tootes goes to the origin it goes up to
the right unless it's been reflected and
that's one period now you can repeat
that and it'll keep you know going in
both directions so great job if you're
able to follow these uh examples here
for this pre-cal midterm exam review if
you want more help if you like these uh
examples and you want some more practice
I have a pre-calculus uh first quarter
exam review and second quarter exam
review that go over some similar topics
uh for some additional practice so
follow me over to those videos right
there and I'll see you there good luck
on your exam